marketing for the now
marketing for the now marketing for the
now marketing for the now
10 minutes 12 remarkable guests
for two hours answering a singular
important question
[Music]
are you ready gary what do you think
hey gary i can't believe it marketing
for the now number 16.
if they're sweet 16. it's a it's a
grown-up now
it's a grown-up now it's also the last
episode
of 2020 i didn't think we would actually
reach the end of 2020 for some reason
but we've got one more question to ask
12 people
one more question which consumer
behavior shifts will be key to driving
growth
in 2021 are you ready
always all right first up we're kicking
off the show with
shark barbara corcoran her credits
include straight d's in high school and
college she had 20 jobs by the time she
turned 23
and then she borrowed a thousand dollars
quit her job as a waitress and started
a tiny real estate company in new york
city that is now
a 5 billion real estate business welcome
barbara
hey my pleasure to be here i love gary
i'll do anything for him
barbara it's great to see you it's
always great to see you happy holidays
uh and pending new year we don't have a
lot of time so i'm gonna get right into
it because i know every
a lot of people were excited they were
going to be on the show so thanks for
kicking us off
in your opinion which consumer behavior
shift
will be key to driving growth in 2021
am i allowed to pick more than one
because i think there's probably four or
five out there okay
yes you are one the customer's in charge
i think if we didn't understand that
before we certainly understand it now
the behavior that we collaborate with
the customer is over with they're in
charge
end of story so i think the key here as
an entrepreneur is you have to stay very
close to your customer and listen hard
and see what they need
and i think the first thing they need is
they want safety and that ain't going to
go away either
and when i say safety i think you have
to put safety first
customers demand it and you don't have
to worry about how to pay for it
because you can't afford to worry about
how to pay for it you just have to do it
i think social media is the fastest and
cheapest way to communicate
what the safety measures your particular
business has done
and i think the social discipline
protocols that we've
all recently encountered are here to
stay as well
uh things like the dots on the floor i
don't expect them to go away next year
at this time
mounted thermometers at at restaurant
doors discretionary mass for travel
i think it's all we're going to just see
a softer version of the same moment
ain't going to go away but safety is
what
people care about now and they will
continue how how long do you
let me jump in on that one uh you know
okay so we see a softening let's say a
year from today
do you think do you see a time where we
go back to 2019 levels or do you think
this is now
stuck in our culture for
quite a long time it's part of our
culture it's not going to go away
would you travel in an airplane whether
you're traveling business class or coach
and not wear a mask i wouldn't
never again i mean i kind of wanted to
do that when people were coughing next
to me but i thought it was socially rude
nope i'm going on the airplane with the
mask forever more i don't want to catch
what's going around
no nothing's going to go away totally
we'll have a residual that will become
part of our culture
definitely understood keep going okay
online shopping is king i mean i almost
feel embarrassed to say that everybody
knows that okay
but i think uh part and parcel of that
is you need to go to where the customer
is i have one business name cousins main
lobster large franchise
of lobster trucks yes i like those guys
yeah those guys i think you interviewed
yeah
yeah a smart entrepreneur but the moment
a covet hit that guy had pivot i hate
the word pivot but i'll have to use it
because i don't know what's the
substitute
he oh he turned his business around
there's a new substitute use
contactless pickup communicating where
his trucks are going to be
and he moved his trucks out of the
normal places that were crowded
and he utilized every single large
shopping mall parking lot
gave people numbers they waited in line
picked up they went home with their
dinner out
and his increase in sales went through
the roof within a month and a half
pretty sharp but he understood he needed
to go to where the customer was
comfortable being
i also have a business that's my most
successful business named comfy
and what it is is a wearable sweatshirt
and what they did is they had 150
million dollars in sales
in big box stores that were sent back to
the one cove it hit
because the big box stores they were
merchandising to had closed
what were they gonna do they increased
their sales online
turned up a website that they hadn't
taken seriously
as before and they turned 150 million
dollars in sales
into 250 million dollars in sales they
went to where the customer wanted to be
that's exactly what they did and then
also again obvious so i hesitate to say
it
social media is the name of the game i
mean i don't invest in a single business
in the season on shark tank unless i
felt that the entrepreneur
was almost a borderline genius on social
media because i know we're going to have
to rely on the social media
platforms forevermore because we have
spoiled our customers with us
and they want it in social media i think
key traits or
or key entrepreneurs or pardon me key
employees that
all of us need as entrepreneurs are now
the producers the storytellers the
videographers
uh it's really become the new norm they
used to be extra people it was nice a
luxury feature if you want but with
social media being the name of the game
it's not the case anymore and barbara
real quick on that i'm trying to
interrupt um when you were building your
real estate
empire so much of it to do with branding
was direct mail a very strong pillar for
you
in the prime of your growth yes it was
but
everyone used direct mail but the way i
was able to
become extremely successful with it is i
use
postcards because i watched people at
home
including myself and i didn't open junk
mail right
i was forced to read that's what we used
yes so you paid
you paid higher to be your individual
postcard versus maybe in a value pack
and and you feel like even though you
were paying more to get into a mailbox
you were getting seen more often and
that gave you a leg up
it gave me a leg up but honestly i never
considered value packs because i'm
too selfish i want my own stage wherever
i am
and i got it on a postcard what was more
effective
uh than the postcard campaigns i
constantly ran was buying billboards 10
cents on the dollar
a lot of people remnant inventory right
an inventory i did the same thing for
wine library
over new york and that put my brand
front line and center
billboards with king and then also what
a lot of people didn't know then that i
took full advantage of is i bought
remnant space in the new york times and
the wall street journal
saved for retailers but when i checked
into their rules
retail was not the rule it was just
shoprite and everybody was using and i
started putting full page advertising
for all my properties that
looked at a billion when i really had 10
cents on the dollar
as well it's funny i i really think your
career in knowing it being an east coast
guy
you know a lot of people think about me
with social media but i
i got my chops in direct mail print
outdoor radio
because because i was advertising as
like a kid from my dad's store
and i think the reason social was so
natural to me
was all the things i learned between
distribution under pr you just basically
talked about underpriced attention
you would buy more strategically around
places that people would look
you took advantage of the remnant cost
or the i did the same exact stuff
on print and outdoor and direct not you
couldn't really do it the same way on
direct mail
but the other thing i learned during
that era because i was doing so much of
it
was the creative was the variable even
though i was buying
the full page new york times ad in the
dining section at a really good price
because i knew when to buy it and how
my ad mattered to how many people i
would get and i think that that
is a big a lot of people watching right
now are like but social's not working
for me and i'm like the creative is the
variable
and the creative also must have the key
ingredient i'm sure you'd agree with me
it has to be authentic people see
through the [ __ ] anymore you know if
you
if your story's not authentic if you
don't connect with them on some basis
i've even gotten rid of makeup in most
of my postings
i find that people respond better to me
looking ugly than old dolled up
authentic is key and i i don't think
that's going to change either of course
i agree with you you got one parting
shot we got a minute i know these are
going quick
okay so one more thing please you need
to be an entrepreneur that thrives on
change
i mean if you don't welcome change and
look for it seek it out like a missile
like
what's next what's next like a kid with
a curiosity box right
you're not going to be ready for the
changes out there i mean change
for me and i don't think i'm imagining
is happening probably twice the rate it
would four years ago
and if you're not aware that today is
the single best opportunity you're ever
going to see again for the next 10 years
of taking over your competitors
marketplace his beat
because you can out perform outcreate
out do whatever you have to do to get
rid of that guy
this is the time to do it the best time
to move ahead is always in the worst
times any smart entrepreneur will tell
you they moved ahead in the worst times
because the big guys are asleep at the
wheel they get tight they get tough
most people go on defense
it's great to see you okay my pleasure
thank you so much for this
ten minutes really thank you very much
next up we've got stephanie buscemi cmo
of salesforce
stephanie leads a global team of 1400
marketers and she's on the a-list
of every cmo award and co-author of
driven to perform
prior to salesforce you held senior
roles at
ihs sap oracle and more welcome
stephanie
hey it's great to be with you thank you
very much pleasure
good to see you um let's get right into
the question
let's do it which consumer behavior
shift or shifts
will be key to driving growth in 2021
from your perspective and maybe one
minute
of context because we have such a mixed
audience on sale force
you know and sas and the business
yeah so just to backdrop on salesforce
real real quick what does salesforce do
we connect customers and companies
together
21 years in the business number one in
customer relationship management
think about 21 years ago the mission of
the company was help sales people
better engage with their customers the
mission hasn't changed
we're just now doing that across all the
touch points so whether it's a service
interaction a commerce interaction a
marketing interaction
and we're orchestrating this so that's
the quick bit
on salesforce um i would say the biggest
thing
that i see now i've seen it with
millennials but i see it now
even more with the pandemic is that it's
it is truly no longer
enough to have just a good product or
service
to reach a full potential there has to
be an emotional connection
building trust with the brand and the
values of the company
um i customer relationships are the
biggest differentiator
and it isn't again just built on your
product and services
uh this generation wants to know what
you're all about
and companies have long talked about
purpose we've all talked about purpose
but i believe this next generation is
holding our feet to the fire
to show it walk the walk don't talk the
talk in fact
there are real consequences for
marketers who
value wash uh and they can't back it up
with programs in terms of
what they're doing we talk a lot about
business as the greatest platform for
change
we're not waiting for anyone else we
believe business can give back and
contribute
to the environment socially economically
and i believe that is going to be a
prerequisite for any company's growth
and success moving forward
i i couldn't agree more talk to me about
speed
you know how you know sitting at such a
senior level you have such a large
company
continue to get larger i was an investor
in slack so
i texted mark thank you for that
transaction
uh how much concern do you have around
how fast the organization is at
creative and media deployment how much
is speed being talked about how much is
context how much is relevance over
awareness are those conversations
relevant right now in salesforce
i would say the number one conversation
is uh the conversations are speed and
relevance
in fact you have uh we we write as a
company our our values
our vision uh for the year every year
it's an exercise we do and
it's really a living breathing document
it's not sort of a one-time exercise
and we had written ours for the calendar
year and then we went into the pandemic
and when we came back together very
quickly we said what do we value most
right now
and its relevance being relevant to our
customers and what they need now
is probably very different from what
they need six months ago so
uh we shifted very quickly a great
example of that is if you had told me at
the beginning of last year
that salesforce would build and make
generally available to our customers
a contact tracing application
employee response management application
and now a vaccine management
application i think our engineers had
that in the cards
in the plan but that's what our
customers wanted and needed from us
and we could do it and so we moved the
organization people went home
virtually on a friday and came to work
on a monday to build these applications
and we've delivered
that's relevance to what our customers
needed now
from a marketing standpoint what do you
think the big you know
sitting at the seat that you have what
do you think the biggest miss
of the collective b2b environment
is you know i think what you know you
saw a lot of b2c
clients have a lot of tv production
dollars go away this year because they
didn't use them because they couldn't
and it's been interesting to see what
they were doing i've had a lot of
conversations at the vayner x level
with b2b marketers who spend and i mean
i always knew b2b companies in the
fortune 5000
spent way too much money on conferences
and booths and things of that nature i
don't think i really understood
how how far along and how egregious
those budgets were
you know a do you do you see that
perspective as well and b
how much you know what when i asked that
question what is the opportunity for
a better job uh for the b2b especially
the b2b sas
industry because we have a lot of people
here marketers but even small startups
what's the miss or or the opportunity
however you want to frame it
the miss is if people aren't completely
getting a match
to the b2b marketing playbook uh the
myth
is that we see a lot of people yes uh
b2b
uh heavy on live events salesforce was
no exception
normally i'd be doing dreamforce in san
francisco right now
the reality though is many are
retrofitting
those conferences and it looks like it
yeah it's really stale it's really dry
um and you have to completely
uh it's not a retrofit you have to
re-engineer
uh your organization it means uh
what you build your talent the
composition b2b
marketing as having a huge shift in
talent that it needs right now
needing to be much more digitally savvy
overweighting on live events
uh talent so there's a talent shift that
needs to happen
there's a reinvention that needs to
happen there i'll give you my
own example we when we thought about
reimagining dreamforce for virtual
we looked at all of the ingredients that
go into dreamforce
inspiration fun learning you know uh
it's a tech conference meets a super
bowl meets a rock concert
it's a baby davos how would we replicate
all of that
in a digital forum and the reality was
we had to decompose it
and then create one to few and one to
many
experiences we there wasn't one online
do you think you think do you think even
also the realization of like hey there's
certain things we're just not going to
be able to replicate so let's not be
ideological and let's get our
practicality hat on
a thousand percent a thousand percent
but people have to be willing to
really get out the white piece of paper
and start over
um i i do see a lot of people
taking their agenda from their user
conference
and then literally just putting it
online
uh it's not gonna work the tv it's like
the tvcs we saw
as youtube and facebook videos in the
early b2c marketing
ecosystem a lot you know it's funny i've
gotten
more emails from friends contemporaries
associates about marketing for the now
they're like hey you're really screwing
me up
your free event is so much more stacked
than the thing that we're trying to sell
as a conference and i think
that and what that makes me think about
is just classic supply and demand and
competition right
like on your point like you know if i
i don't i'm not going to spend millions
on the catering bill in the venue but
when it comes to
being able to bring the best marketers
in the world together in a virtual
setting
we have that leverage and if you know
and even in the comments right now i'm
reading it a lot of people like
this is better than the stuff i've paid
for that's a real challenge
if you don't know what to do with that
yeah i think uh
it's democratized it's open open the
field for everyone
i'll say a positive on it is that
if you can think it and get it right
digitally
the access is incredible so i look at it
right now
and think about our c-level engagement
our c-level engagement with ceos of
from around the world is up about 25
because the the price of entry to say
give me 20 minutes on a zoom or
even 30-year and even an hour and it's
not
can you come to new york meet at this
dinner you know we're able to engage
but it's how you engage you only get
that one chance to make a first
impression here
and it is uh i right now would say the
most effective things
are when you're getting 10 people or
under
in a highly curated digital environment
um and it's peer group these you know
loaded deck into a virtual pre-recorded
and
blast it to hundreds of thousands of
people they tend to be a sleeper
yeah that's gonna work no scaling the
unscalable
right stephanie i really appreciate your
time i know you're busy
and hope you have a wonderful and
healthy holiday you too
great seeing you gary take care
next we welcome kofi amu godfrey the vp
of marketing for doordash he's had a
career of leading great brands
including facebook and bacardi and was
agent seaside at
fcb and founder of publicis west africa
he's won ad color's rock star award and
he's married to his high school
sweetheart
how are you my friend gary what's good
man it's a real pleasure coffee
and congrats i know it's exciting times
back at the uh
home base for your company indeed uh
let's just get right into it because
i've been really dying to see where your
take was going to be on this
which consumer behavior shifts will be
key
to driving growth in 2021 from your
perspective
yeah gary there's there's two that i'm
thinking about so the the first is that
there's like a demand for comfort
right so so we released this trend
report that we do every year doordash
it's called the state of flavor
and it looked at like what people were
ordering on the platform right so
the top three things chicken fingers and
fries
chicken sandwich and uh and mac and
cheese but then if you looked at like
what things were trending in terms of
like you know year-over-year percentages
over a thousand going into the next year
sausage sausage egg and cheese on a
biscuit create your own omelet
carrot cake right so that's just like
the food category but it was all comfort
foods
coffee which one of those comfort foods
that you just mentioned is your personal
favorite and which one do you
and which one just of those not your
overall coffee spectrum
wow maybe sausage egg and cheese on a
biscuit
but but i think this is a trend that
we've seen across multiple categories i
think many of you guest speakers today
will be wearing like nice shirts
and sweatpants right like where we're in
this mode now okay or no
no no maybe no pants but we're in this
mode where
comfort is what people are focused and i
think you know i look at categories like
makeup and you think about
we've all been sitting here and people
are not not been wearing makeup so what
does that
what does that mean for like when the
world opens up or new clothes
you know on new clothes yeah i mean
that's sneakers i mean
yeah sneaker game is whack right it's
gone it takes over
yeah your sneaky game is like socks
slots under yeah
so i really like that i think you nailed
it yeah so i think comfort is going to
be a big one i expect to see that go on
the other one which is on
totally opposite side of this is a
demand for corporations to have a
conscience
right i mean we've talked for years gary
you've seen all the reports like
consumers want to vote with their
dollars and they want to align with
their values
and i think that's been true but i think
it's only been true up to a point you
know all of us have been like
i've certainly done this delete uber and
then like you open the lyft app and
there's no car and you're like
maybe maybe maybe i'll actually use it
and cope you know what it also
is is look when you you know businesses
at scale
inherently are going to have some sort
of social vulnerability
correct i mean you can't wear a designer
clothing
you can't wear clothes if you're if
you're extreme
on the environment because textiles are
doing more damage than a lot of sectors
that's right that's exactly right i've
been scolded
for a plastic bottle by one of my
friends while they're wearing a gucci
belt and i'm like do the math you're
like what are you
you're like what are you doing you know
and i think
what i i think it's a very important era
because i do think this is going to come
up more
however it gets into incredibly
incredibly interesting territories
because
at some level once you start picking at
this everyone's going to be vulnerable
about something yeah this this is
exactly right i think the thing that's
interesting is
before was the vulnerability was
actually confined to your core business
right so it's like if you're like a
textiles company i'm gonna talk to you
about the environment
i think the big shift that we've seen
this year is that
all the third rail stuff that companies
could actually sit out
you can't sit out anymore right so for a
long time on issues of race
neutrality was a safe haven like no
brands were expected to speak out about
race it's like hey
sit this one out like i'll talk about
environmental i'll talk about some other
thing i will not engage on this issue
what's been fascinating this year is
that like silence is being interpreted
as speech
so if you didn't say anything people are
going to have questions
but if you do say something but and you
can't back it up and this is the point
that stephanie with
stephanie was making you're going to get
hammered for that as well the truth is
you know
somebody said to me the other day gary
you talk about the same [ __ ] i'm like
exactly
i'm like i'm very focused on talking
about the things i know
and i and i i have no interest because i
put myself so out there i have no
interest to talk about things i don't
know
i need to come in with curiosity and
empathy and
and those things i think it's wild let
me ask you a question what about speed
of creative uh
very you know you're a more contemporary
modern company
you come from this incredible uh
background creatively uh
marketing wise you know curious about
your juxtaposition of your career
now that you've got a couple years
underneath it you know uh
my perspective coming into the industry
was it was unconscious
i was fascinated by the lack of speed
yeah door dash
speed of create you know especially a
company that's going to understand
things like cac and ltv on an app that's
right
you know i would argue that probably a
little bit more of the challenge is
building top of the funnel brand
because the math stuff's there but what
about the creative output because i
think the math based companies
tend to understand a lot except brand
building in the lower funnel
and not enough volume of creative and
saying a channel doesn't work when they
only did seven creative variables
when there's so much more and it's less
about iterations about ideas and
creative
in that world you know knowing your
background a little bit i was like
excited to ask you about this
all that i just threw at you break that
down your perspective what you're seeing
where you've got advancements to go at
doordash
or what you've seen work well yeah it's
a terrific question and i think like to
your point you know i
i grew up on the agency side where like
you know preciousness
was the vector uh rather than speed and
and sort of
and yeah but subjective opinion
a hundred percent
yeah that's cause like that's not the
answer right the answer is like actually
figuring out what's working and what
isn't i think what's been fascinating at
door has
is i think we found a good balance so
you know really good example from
earlier this year is like
we turned around and fully integrated
campaign in six days when the pandemic
hit
i think we were the first major brand to
go to market and say actually hey the
job right now is like let's not speak
about doing ash let's encourage people
to support
all of the restaurants whether they're
doing it on our platform or on other
platforms
but we turned that around in six days
you know which like
didn't even feel possible from a
trafficking perspective but turns out
turns out you can do that and we did
that all the way through the funnel
and i think we're figuring out working
with you know in the bottom of the
funnel in the middle of funnel we have a
wide variety of partners we're working
with
to create lots of options around
creative right we're going to we want to
have the brand consistency
we want to have the brand point of view
but we also want to like create the
space to figure out what's actually
working rather than assuming that we're
going to have all the answers
to your point we call it a vayner x
finding right and that's right end up
having the audacity of thinking you're
right
that's right that's exactly right talk
to me about tick tock you know
the consumer attention you know we're
again we're og enough to see
facebook go from a college kids platform
that's right a great grandparents
platform that's right
are you starting to take that platform
seriously
yeah we are look i think we started this
year i don't think we figured it out in
all honesty i think this past year this
was the first year that we started
playing in tick tock
um we did some interesting stuff again
early on in the pandemic
around driving support for restaurants
that resonated really well we
participated in this influencer
challenge called the do your part
challenge
in partnership with feeding america to
drive meal donations but also to drive
restaurant support
we saw a ton of traction around that um
like billions of impressions
so we know there's something there um i
don't think we figured out how to do
this consistently yet so this is one of
the areas um that we're going to be
looking at going into
21. what about ott commercials
you know the the this really interesting
evolution of roku
amazon fire stick hulu you know
obviously
not every ott has commercial
infrastructure but is that something
you're spending more time thinking about
because i see that eating up a ton of
the commercial
television space but it has more dna in
instagram facebook youtube like buying
and creative
has that hit your radar is that a debate
internally a hundred percent we're
spending a lot of time on that gary like
we're finding
hey that like those spaces are like
totally
gold deeply measurable how much under
price because the demand
yeah correct supplies you know demand
correct that's good for you
correct does that put challenges on your
creative agencies to make five
commercials
that are quality for the price of what
the kind of things you were accustomed
to years ago has that pressure on the
cost of creative
i mean this all goes to one place
creative's too expensive in the
advertising world
are you starting to have those
conversations yeah i think we're trying
to figure it out yeah i don't know that
we've cracked that particular thing yet
because i do think there's
there's things that we want to do at a
very high fidelity right so we
should which so but then i think the
question is
does it need to cost that much it does
not that is to me
you can make a super bowl spot for a
hundred thousand that right bonkers
amazing that's right
you could that's right industry has
decided you can't
that's right and i wonder with your
incredible agency background and being
in a more contemporary company
the reason i think this series you can
see my energy's high hey because i
respect you from afar and i'm excited to
get connected but b
i think you having one foot in both
places leads to the marketers that i
think are gonna create change i came
so from the other place that people
viewed my opinions on this as
not right wrong [ __ ] or
or you know uh disruptor i'm like no no
this shit's practical
yeah it's just true and i think watching
great
uh marketers come from agencies of that
kind of fidelity
to go into companies like this are going
to be the ones that actually drive the
change
makes sense yeah 100 i mean i always
think that like my job is to figure out
how to merge the two things that
like i know now right like when when i
joined facebook many years ago i didn't
have this like data-driven
funnel i have that now correct and so
how do you merge that with like the
creativity
from like widening kennedy and bacardi
and all that how do you bring all of
that together
this was a real pleasure good to hang my
dad talk to you soon
later fired up to have
bozema st john cmo of netflix join us
next
bose just took the role in june
previously previously holding c-suite
roles at endeavour
uber apple and pepsi she serves on the
boards of girls who code
and vital voices welcome bows thank you
hey gary what up
right off the bat before i get into the
actual question what does it
actually feel like to be walking around
on earth
being the coolest cmo in the world both
because of your
who you are as the human and because of
the company you get to
now be at the top of from a marketing
standpoint
is it weird like how are you feeling out
there
i feel like a badass how about that yeah
yes but i've i felt that way from birth
you know what i mean i've been walking
around this planet
like i've had something to contribute to
it for a very long time so
this hasn't really changed anything for
me internally although
i can see from the excitement of other
people that this is a pretty big deal so
i feel good about that
before i go into the question one last
thing how many times have you been
texted
by your friends or former uh
contemporaries or
your inner circles about queen's gambit
oh
yes so much
first of all you know shocker i mean
honestly just the shocker right
i think sleepy hit nobody knew that it
was coming but
pretty it felt pretty big pretty quickly
you know and and
the fact that there are people who have
like
you know seen upticks in uh chess
playing
the sales data it's it's outrageous
but so cool that you know we have a
young woman
right who is star in it uh and she plays
a genius in this particular
role is incredible i think it's just
like a testament to the fact that
storytelling can change perception
across culture so dope yes
which consumer behavior shifts
will be key in driving growth in 2021
from your perspective
ah well okay so gary like this is the
thing
is that like i am endlessly curious
about people right
i mean it's it's part of the reason why
i'm in marketing because i
really love consumer behavior uh and
this time
has just been one of those where i don't
think any of us have the answer
right we're all being trying to figure
it out day by day it's like if you had a
plan
that you wrote 18 months ago that joint
is trash
you know there's nothing you know i
don't care who you are
how smart you think you are if you think
you know what's going to even happen 12
months from now
you are lying you know way for us to
understand that
so it's better to understand what is
happening right now right at this very
moment like how are you paying attention
so obviously as we're talking marketing
for the now
this is this is the key you know what is
the what is the behavior that is
happening in this very moment that we
could pay attention to now i'm not
saying it's a predictor
it's just that like hey open your eyes
one of them the
you use this word in talking to kofi
about juxtaposition
which i actually think is such an
interesting idea that behavior
is in the extremes at this moment there
are no middle
there are no middles it's like there's
this huge toxic
juxtaposition that i'm seeing in what we
call like conserving
and then on the other hand hoarding you
know that and i'm not
like passing judgment on either one of
those it's just the behavior too
observation
yeah it's like think about this right
all of us are at the beginning of the
pandemic and even i would say today
you know talking about how much more we
can do with less
you know all of those memes start to
rise like i'm so grateful for what i
have
like i'm thankful for this roof over my
head i'm thankful for the food
gratitude yeah all of that right we
started thinking about the things that
we actually need in order to live do i
need all this stuff no i don't
right and then on the other side it's
like oh
toilet paper is that available no you
know why because people start hoarding
it
oh my goodness amazon booming business
you know because we just
keep seeing packages arrive at people's
doors like this
this idea that there there is no sort of
middle ground
that either we're on this side or this
side and at the same damn time
yeah the most incredible behavior i
think i've ever witnessed
because what um you know you've been
incredible actually rattled it off real
quick because i think
it's inspiring rattle off the places
you've been uh leading up marketing over
the last five or six years
oh gosh well five or six uh let's see
beats music
by apple then i uh helped to create
apple music
ran itunes also movies uh books and news
and then endeavor uh i'm sorry uber oh
look i'm
getting uber then endeavor and now at
netflix
so you've been at these very progressive
very you know iconic
companies what what's been most
different about netflix from even those
really progressive companies that you've
been at what was the first
you know i always think it's cool when
you get under the hood obviously you
know all about it
you decide to take the job you do you go
through your due diligence they tell you
you've got your intuition you are
extremely to the pulse which is why
you and i have been friends for so long
but now you walk in
and virtually i guess these days the
halls what's the big observation of like
oh yeah you know what um
okay so caveat is that i've been at the
job for four months right so
you're still you're still tasting
exactly yeah and also
also not in the building right yeah um
so i
actually really love the culture uh of
netflix
you know it's much written about um
clearly it's like even
reid just uh you know published a book
the no rules rules right
um which talks about a netflix culture i
just think it's a fascinating place to
be and that
there really are the empowered people
that are inside of the company doing the
things that they do because they are
truly the best of what they do you know
and that this empowerment allows for
freedom to actually make changes
and make decisions about the business in
ways that i have never seen before
i think it's a really um big point
especially as we look at like the future
of
corporate cultures clearly as we've just
said i've been
a lot of places you know where hierarchy
is important where you have to get
alignment you know the
my favorite word when it comes when it
comes to work because it's like
you know alignment is like the death of
good ideas you know
oh my god it's back to what we're
talking about with speed the elimination
speed yes business is sports and if
speed is not part of your equation
you are vulnerable listen all the way
vulnerable because honestly it's like
and then why do you have people that you
don't empower
you know i'm like like why if they've
got to ask for permission for every
single thing they do then you're not
actually like
utilizing them to the best of their
ability and so for me it's been a really
incredible uh time in the last four
months even though really strange
because starting a job like this and the
pandemic is just like
ridiculous i mean it's literally so wild
it's like
you know i remember i was having this
conversation with ted and he said
he was like well you know folks who try
something new
in this pandemic especially a big job
he's like we're
i think those are the ones who like are
the most adventurous the ones who might
win
so i was like oh god i hope i was like i
hope that comes true for me
uh but you know it's been it's been
really really interesting i think for
lots of people who are trying to refine
who they are you know and redefine it
and perhaps even try something new
that like you know perhaps we are the
crazy ones and that's that's the beauty
i agree let me do some rapid fire in my
last two minutes i'm gonna
so throw a couple things that are very
contemporary i'd love to get your hot
takes
where do you stand on influencer
marketing oh i always think it's good
but like what is this buzzword that
we're using you know
influencers are just people who are
closer to the center of the heat of the
thing
you know and and that thing could be
anything it could be cooking and it
could be shoes
it could be fashion it could be medicine
but the thing is that like we've created
this idea in this meme as if they're
only the cool kids
and that's not influencers are not just
the cool kids influencers are the people
who are closest to the heat
i agree and then when you contextualize
it for example if
queen's gambit had an influencer
campaign before that movie comes out
the chess influencers on instagram are
not necessarily the cool kids but
they're the relevant kids
that's absolutely right yes they are
they are at the center and that's what
influence is all about
what do you think about sms marketing
we've we've all as
american consumers have protected our
text number but we're starting to see it
and i've been surprised but it's
starting to open up thoughts on that
ah personalization is key you know it's
like i don't care if it's sms or
email or facebook paid social it's like
if you're not personalizing to me that i
don't want to see that trash
you know so yeah i'm like listen let's
not do the mass message thing
do you think way to make it personal do
you think that that's one of the bigger
vulnerabilities of television
commercials they have to be vanilla and
they're trying to reach everyone
thus they're reaching nobody yes
absolutely it's like
the tv ad and billboards and all of the
mass
media type of spaces are supposed to be
the anchor you know they're supposed to
be the big one that's like okay
now that you have context for what i'm
about to tell you now i'm going to tell
you why
it's important to you and so therefore
now sms
email or any other social like i just
said any other place where i can get
more personal
that's to help to get to the center of
what i want to communicate with you
do you think we've gotten to such a you
know digital personal world
that the costs associated with that
anchor you know the production costs and
the distribution costs of those things
are really expensive
thoughts on the price value of that
these days no not really i mean the
thing is it still
holds true right it's like you're still
getting a lot of reach for the
for the media and so i don't think the
price issue is a problem i just think
that we've got to reevaluate the
priorities you know what is going to be
the most important thing
is it that i want lots of reach i want
lots of coverage everywhere
what happens what happens when you're
netflix and you have that kind of
awareness
well i mean that's the thing is that the
awareness is not just about the brand
but now you got to have awareness on
titles
you know like all of the shows and
listen it's like if you don't know what
queen's gambit is now i gotta go tell
you
so that's that's the news for you and
your company almost everybody knows what
kings gambit is
it's such a pleasure i'm cheering for
you daily oh thank you gary sam
next up we've got michelle paluso the
cmo of ibm
and svp of digital sales
hey gary is responsible for billions of
revenue and accountable for demand
generation with the team across a
hundred countries
prior to ibm michelle was ceo of gil
global cons marketing and internet
officer of citigroup
and ceo of travelocity she's won too
many awards to mention
welcome michelle hello hello so excited
to be here and that was so much fun
listening to kofi and bows
thank you michelle so you've had an
incredible career i'm so glad we're
getting this time together
because we haven't had the luxury to jam
too too much so first
it's great to see you thank you for
doing this um
let's just actually let's get right into
it and then we'll side dish let's get
right into the meat
from your perspective michelle what are
the consumer behaviors
uh the shifts and and the keys to
driving business in 2021
that are unique to where we're going
look the
amazing thing about this year is every
company on the planet has had to become
digital overnight
extraordinary thing we've been talking
about this for so many years and to see
now
literally every industry every company
becomes digital overnight is incredible
and you know what gary it's not
just the consumer apps the mobile device
the website
it's actually the supply chain this the
factory
manufacturing i mean all these things
have that customer service
all these fundamental parts of companies
have had to digitize overnight
and that you know that's actually a
tremendous uh tremendous thing when you
think about it that that won't change
not only is that affecting of course
consumer behavior it's affecting all the
backend processes of companies
but even more think about how much data
think about the explosion of data that
this provides
for marketers and it's that marriage
that kofi that juxtaposition he was
talking about you know this like deep
data driven marketing with the creative
the brand the purpose the empathy the
curiosity the authenticity so
it's really been a remarkable year for
for companies and certainly for
marketers
what do you think about in
contemporizing
such an iconic brand like ibm yeah right
yeah like you know nine-year-old tech
company when does that
it's like i i think it's the coolest
because i'm a nostalgia
history kind of human but i have
you know i think about my every time i
do things like this i'm like what would
i do if i had that job
and i think you know watson has been an
incredible contemporary driver
for people that are paying attention for
ibm but in general
it is a fun challenge yeah for sure how
do you keep this brand you know fresh
after 109 years of being a high-tech
company
what other high-tech company has existed
for 109 years
i think a few things number one it's
never really been about what we sell
i mean we sold cheese slicers and and
you know
counters and clocks obviously now it's
about cloud and artificial intelligence
and quantum computing and blockchain
so it can't be anchored the brand isn't
anchored on what we sell the brand is
anchored on
changing how the world works era after
era and the values i mean there's so
many things about ibm
that you know no brand can exist for all
these years without being authentic
and so you know all sorts of things like
in 1953 we our ceo wrote policy letter
number four
we would never discriminate against any
person based on rey's sex
identification our pay equity rules for
the company
were in place in the 1930s so there's
certain values that are part of
who ibm is how we operate in the world
that
you know era after era after era are
still true and that's what's exciting as
a
from a brand challenge when i look at
your title
digital sales and cmo it excites me
because
i grew up in an environment where i was
a natural entrepreneur and marketer
but my dad had a liquor store and i had
to care about sales
every day you know sasha vaynerchuk
wasn't fooling around he didn't care
what marketing looked like he wanted to
know how much
champagne sold that you know what i mean
but
because it was a family business i knew
my dad would die in that building when
he was 100 years old
hopefully i always cared about brand
because i knew i would eventually leave
and do my own thing
and i wanted that brand to like get him
to that you know
i love that and i share that passion for
entrepreneurship and we also share
entrepreneur fathers so my dad was also
an entrepreneur and built a business and
i sat around his kitchen table
as he talked about clients and people i
mean gary he would grill us
before the company picnic michelle
what's the name of sally's little
i love that
you know i find a lot of cmos are either
really strong at one or the other
very strong at brand i think the best
are the best have to do both and i
most of my career i've been a ceo so
i've sat in that seat most of my career
you know and so i think it gives you a
perspective of like well what are the
levers of the p now how do you make this
company work how do you bring
diverse skills creative analytical
legal sales tech you know development
how do you bring that together so
i i just have i think both said this so
well that curiosity that
passion for you know really trying to
understand what the what the night sky
looks like from different sides of the
world and a
deep abiding belief that the best cmos
you know are not
at the table because they're a cmo
they're at the table because they're an
advisor
on how to best grow and position the
business for all stakeholders
so that's exciting right that's a huge
remit
talk to me about linkedin creative you
know when i think about your business
i think the biggest elephant in the room
in all of marketing
is the lack of advancements in linkedin
marketing by b2b companies it feels to
me
very similar to what i lived through in
2012 and 13 on facebook
for consumer brands over the last three
to four years has clearly become
more of a content and social network the
paid
capabilities are remarkable though
they're expensive in comparison to other
platforms which could but i always tell
people but they're more valuable
customers
yeah so sometimes it justifies that cost
but look here
in the past few interviews you're poking
out a few really important issues
um there is nothing about this year that
says that we should do things the same
next year
um you know we had to pull all of our
creative down in you know in a matter of
days and all the pandemic
we were up with a new creative and new
platform
fully shot fully produced media
trafficked in 11 days
and actually that stuff was at you know
of course a fraction of the cost
and performing better than you know some
of our ads previously
you've been poking on this in each of
those discussions the cost
differently can we take the cost down
can if we do that
can have hyper personalized creative and
then places like linkedin become really
powerful right because the point about
linkedin is you have got to personalize
you have so much information about
what company this person's at what their
job role is what they're interested in
what their profile looks like
you don't get that on tv you don't get
that in print right so it's
highly valuable but the only way to make
the economics really work is if
actually you have a cost effective model
and creative side
that can match that personalization with
the right person so i think that's some
of the breakthroughs we've all got to
you know really triumph frankly in in
2021 and beyond
just a little quick little thing here
for the last two minutes because i see a
lot of people being inspired by your
career
how does somebody think about getting
into big business
a lot there's a lot of people watching
right now that are in my community
who have an entrepreneurial flair but i
also am pushing so much around
self-awareness and a lot of them are
realizing wait a minute i am not an
entrepreneur
but i want to but i want to be a big dog
in these companies
thought what what do you tell young
people what do you tell
you know you know the people that reach
out to you for mentorship what's a good
thing to think about
a little hack for 2021 to give them a
little extra leverage to break into
marketing or operations in fortune 5000
companies
yeah great question you know i when
you're young in your career
the most important thing i think is to
surround yourself with people you're
going to learn from be curious
and surround yourself with people you're
going to learn from and and i i stress
that because when i really think about
my career i i there's so many people i
can point to
who got me from here to there who had
honesty to sit me down and be like
michelle
you know this is not this isn't good
enough you could do better what if you
put it this way like what if you tried
there's so many people i emulated so
many people i watched
and i'm so grateful that i chose you
know i chose wisely frankly i had
amazing
mentors and bosses and colleagues and i
was a sponge
you know nobody worked harder and
nobody's so brutal
and and that served me well in my
entrepreneurial career
um that curiosity that desire to
surround myself with great people that
just that work ethic
and it's really served me well in my
kind of big company career as well so
i think that you know be a sponge be
curious and really if
you know i remember my very first job
offer uh i had an offer from mckinsey an
offer from bcg
and the mckinsey offer treated me as a
consultant much more money much more
prestige
bcd a lot less because they didn't treat
my my oxford degree as a graduate degree
i took the bcg because i knew i would
learn faster and learn more because of
the people there so i i
really highly prioritize make sure the
number one deciding factor is
are you around people who are going to
teach you to get better and be a sponge
i love it michelle thank you for your
time great to see you take care
excited to welcome deborah wahl global
cmo of general motors
deborah was appointed in 2019 previously
serving as the global cmo of cadillac
prior to joining gm deborah served as
the svp and cmo of mcdonald's
proudly bringing us all day breakfast
she's held leadership roles at pulte
group chrysler and lexus
welcome welcome deborah thank you so
much
great to be here hi gary hey deborah
this is like the uh
mount rushmore of like marketing i'm
really andrew i'm really proud of you
this is
this is crazy deborah it is so great to
see you
um what is
in your opinion the the opportunities
the shifts the things that big companies
and small companies need to be thinking
about to really win the day in 2021 what
are the
what what is the emerging opportunity
from your purview
so i i think if 20 taught us anything it
was we got to really stay close to
customers and that everything's changing
super fast and so it's almost on a day
by day week by week basis that we're
evolving
and i think the opportunity is that's
changed everything
especially in larger companies small
companies as well i'm sure
i'll just speak from my experience but
we have this thing that we talk about
now that's called ventilator time
you know when when there was that need
for ventilators we got them to market
in like 18 days from the first meeting
to when we set up the whole
uh supply chain and assembly line to do
them so that has now been sort of the
call to action
for everything i think that's going to
go further in marketing we've always had
this thing that we've always been like
we're behind the customer we all have to
get a
customer right so i i think now
we're operating at speed with the
customer how do we do that in big
companies you know i came into this
industry
because i couldn't agree with what you
just said more i'm like my god
this brief to creative to television
down to matching luggage on digi i mean
this takes forever what
how like it i was like a foreign alien
to this process and to be frank it
hasn't changed
so remarkably in 12 years deborah do you
think 2020
is a tipping point where context speed
and relevance i mean you have a massive
brand
in general motors i have empathy for top
of the funnel stuff that stuff i
spoke with bose but but my point is your
your cars are known
but the relevancy is the issue do you
think the agency
the internal the job description like
what is it really
gonna take for this industry to get
faster because
everyone's hyped about what happened in
2020 but i'm not seeing the systematic
change that's required to actually win
on speed and relevance
yeah i i think a couple things you know
going through the arc of a career you
think all right we were
really big on just brand ideas 25 years
ago then we went through this whole
thing that efficiencies and costs and
all this analysis and everything became
priorities and it and it really slowed
things down and now i think we're
finding
the balance i don't think everyone's
mastered it at all yet but we're
certainly pushing where suddenly we're
we're unleashing things so that we can
just get stuff done
um because that's the priority now and
we're good at
being efficient and we're good at you
know taking costs out of systems
and we're kind of whittling down all
those things and certainly data
platforms et cetera have helped us so
that we know we're
being more efficient so i think it's in
a whole different mindset
and then what i think our experience in
you know work from home has actually
pulled all of us together closer so that
we're more unified on what we're getting
done
because we just don't have time to mess
around you know you don't have all the
time
where you were in the office and you
could have meetings and things like that
suddenly
it's much more precious and urgent that
we're all focused and aligned on the
same thing so that we're
we're going faster and that unleashes
all kinds of time
so on a on on a product like a
car that has a you know the difference
between buying
a vehicle from general motors and buying
all day breakfast at mcdonald's you
couldn't
you couldn't be this is what i love
about your career one has
the one of the longest lead times
right and path and journey and and the
other has one of the fastest
what break that down for me because i
think there might be some fun insights
and i think it can help certain
your marketers that might be hesitant to
switch to a different kind of
you know consumer consideration path
maybe you can give them some
encouragements or what you learned or
what
what you stuck your toe on yeah i've
always gone um from
mazel's hierarchy all the way up and
down i have elkhorn homes i've got
food i've got you know mobility all that
um but you know the constant from
the the whole constant is creating value
and understanding what your consumers
really need and how the heck you get it
to them faster
and in a different way than anyone else
and what was interesting about
mcdonald's
i always say i went from patties to
caddies and i love that idea
but um the interesting thing about
mcdonald's is there is so much
robust um professionalism in the whole
process
it is almost as hard and and takes
that kind of engineering knowledge to
efficiently get a whole meal to market
in the time frame that does there as
when we're building a car it's
incredible you know it does it takes
it takes a really lot of testing and
understanding so
um so i think as long as you're focused
on the core values and understand
what consumers value that they'll
actually part with their dollar for
that's the common thing and then
marketing is exciting because we're just
innovating all the time we've got to
think about how to do it in a different
way different from anyone else and where
to go so
i find enormous flexibility that's why i
love this industry this career
everything that we do it never stops
being challenging and exciting
talk to me about audio what do you think
the place of podcasts
or even getting information from alex or
google home is that starting to hit your
radar
i'm trying to think of like some new
topics to talk about in this show
yesterday's episode was curious about
your point of view on that
oh yeah i mean uh we're looking well
first of all i think our whole media mix
has changed dramatically and everything
that we've gone through
has accelerated that change people
aren't in their cars all the time so
i don't get my favorite podcast anymore
like i used to on all the drives
but i do find incredible value in how
they're doing it so
i mean we just did a new opportunity
with
carlos watson and ozzie that's really
fascinating work with axios i mean
i think you're looking at these
multi-channel ways that um
people are getting out the daily updates
and the other content that people are
clicking on and finding their time and
making their time for
but what's important in all that is it's
new ways of engaging
at a deeper level than a 30-second
commercial and everything you spend
you know a half hour to an hour podcast
on topics um
so we're following that um incredibly i
think our
our whole media mix as we've gone to
following the person
is changing dramatically the theme that
keeps coming up
cost of creative what's what's your hot
take on that
um so two pieces of it please
storytelling still even more important
now than once
before always and i do find that when
you
you put more into the story that people
get a lot more out of it they
want that extra so i don't mind cost in
that area at all
i do think you consider that the
ideation part or did you consider that
the actual making of it part
both because i think sometimes in
production values are important
in telling the story in a really good
way i mean we're asking everyone to get
so much better at
telling everything visually you know you
don't want to necessarily read or see a
chart
something you have to tell it visually
and that requires some
some potentially more but on the other
hand we're also looking at
how are we so much more efficient one
piece of content goes
in a thousand different places and so
and i'm sure everyone's saying the story
the minute we do
any story and we're doing anything we
have to envision that it's going to go
in 100 places not just in one medium
and i think that's where we come back to
get the efficiencies out the other thing
is we learned in the pandemic when
everyone had to shut down production 100
that the more we had in the bank
that was prepared that was ready to go
the better off we were
you know so those brands that had that
um got a lot further and that's probably
a wise thing to do because
the one thing we know for sure is that i
don't think the roller coaster is going
to end anytime soon
what about you the human being the debra
as a social media consumer
what platforms do you have and enjoy
if any uh my favorite is actually
linkedin now
yeah because it's just um it's it it
it's less about the whole ego idolatry
of some of the other things that we see
and it's just a great way to see what
everyone's catching up
you find it more informative and
educational i do and i don't find it
with all the buy
and all the different you know all the
political disparity and everything
that's going on right now
the other platform so um i'm ex i i get
very excited about that
my boss just jumped in so i'm gonna have
to go but i have a lot of fun
are we done already we're done it goes
ten minutes it goes fast ever
wonderful holiday all right thanks bye
we welcome next suki sandu the ceo
and founder of odelis and involve suki
is one of the leading specialists
in sourcing exceptional diverse talent
and growing it and has been a game
changer for almost 20 years
and he was awarded an obi from the queen
welcome spooky everyone hi
suki it's great to see you how are you
i'm good very good i bought the queen
with me
behind me i'm a little bit concerned i
expect
the uh you know scotland yard to come in
there and like
think you're kidnapping the queen is
very high risk she's like my guardian
angel she's been with me for years
let's get right into the meat of the
conversation which consumer behavior
shifts
will be key to driving uh growth in 2021
or what are the opportunities that
you're seeing from
your different purviews yeah it's
interesting so
2020 has been a really tough year for
everyone i think everyone is just
waiting to get to the holiday break
and i think what we've learned this year
that we've had two pandemics to deal
with
we've had the pandemic recovered and
then the pandemic of racism with black
lives matter and the protest
and i think it's been an awakening year
for everyone so i think 2021
has is definitely going to be about
taking action and
being held accountable for your actions
and it's the consumers or employees
who are going to make this action happen
so for me learning was this year
next year is about seeing action and
seeing brands actually taking action on
diversity and inclusion
much do you think the consumer are
keyboard warriors
this is really you know i was really
excited that you were going to be part
of this because i i wanted to tap into
your brain on this one
when i say keyboard warriors i mean they
pontificate
on social media of what they're going to
do to hershey's if they don't do that
but then their actions in reality you
know i think back to
bp having the big oil spiel or exxon or
tylenol perrier there's there's a lot of
history
in in consumer behavior of voicing
things but then not acting on them is
that something that you are
thinking about seeing do you have any
thoughts on that yeah absolutely and
gary
i think what you're talking about it's
about being an inclusive brand and being
an inclusive brand is about being
authentic
so for instance your ceo can't make a
grand statement about supporting blm
if they have no black representation of
the leadership team of the board
for instance who have put a lot of their
brand success on african-american sports
stars
yet less than five percent of the us
employees are black
and they were called out really strongly
for that in the wake of blm
and to be to me the question is does
that
have have we seen the indication that
that
is affecting their business because
that's what i've been interested about
there's the reverse of it
we've seen so much cancelling on both
sides of the political spectrum
and then when you look under the hood
you know
you're not seeing the mapping yet i i do
think you know you're seeing
it's actually stunning to me how little
you're seeing on the mapping for how
much people are talking and it goes back
to words are cheap
and i was curious if you had any
insights or historical references or
intuitions or points of view on that
phenomenon
yeah because i think well if you think
about the yeezys are selling out
yeah no but i would say that when um
people when when companies
well consumers i suppose are boycotting
brands so they're not buying the product
it it's not just about the revenues it's
about the other impact it has
on the reputation on their ability to
attract
talent and obviously their ability to
retain them because consumers are also
their employees so whatever consumers
are thinking i don't think businesses
can really avoid
what's happening in the market in terms
of responding to blm
thinking about representation in their
own business
or things like companies being accused
of pink washing where
they add the rainbow brand to their
brand for pride month but then they
might not have policies that protect
lgbt employees such as trans inclusion
or same-sex benefits i mean shockingly
in the us for instance there are still
15 states
where you can legally legally be allowed
to fire some of being lgbt plus which i
think is outrageous
so i think actually employees and the
activism that we're seeing in the market
is they're not afraid of holding ceos
and leadership teams accountable
and they do boycott brands even
something like dolce gabbana for
instance where
i remember years ago when they said you
know gay couples having babies by
a ivf were synthetic yeah i mean i
personally will never buy anything from
that brand
actually their sales did plummet after
that i it very very
quickly so growing up as a kid
what what what kind of activities did
brands do to capture your attention
and then and then as a grown-up what
kind of thing so juxtaposition that like
what do you think you were drawn to
one from age one to twenty if you rewind
your con
your personal consumer behavior and what
what have you been attracted to or what
do you look for what
catches your eye obviously you and i are
spending some time up here in a very
serious and important conversation up
here but even going down to the
lightest things of like color schemes or
placement or
social media content or digital tv when
you hear that question how do you think
well i mean it's interesting because
when i i grew up in a very um strict
indian
household so my my dad came to the uk
when he was
six in the 60s so i would say i didn't
really have any perception of brands if
anything like being a working-class
family
it was about kind of saving every penny
that you could and it was very much a
culture of saving rather than spending
sorry i'm sorry more utility right food
utility yeah absolutely and then
obviously as i started to earn
in my early 20s and working obviously
that's what i wanted to spend
working class boy like buying even
designer clothes i buy in the sale
because i feel like i've got my parents
at each shoulder
telling me don't you dare buy that new
seasoned laser from burberry
so i think and now i've moved into an
era where i've just turned 40
and this year i promised to be more
sustainable i was thinking i didn't need
to buy lots of clothes that have a great
wardrobe
and then when you're seeing brands like
patagonia for instance where
you know they they did a campaign um
just for black friday recently but don't
buy this jacket
because we were trying to get consumers
to consider purchasers and the
environmental impact
and championing sustainability so for me
like i feel like
that for me it's about trying to save
the planet and i think a lot of
consumers think in that way too
yeah i mean there's clearly so much
evolution in
the most interesting thing about
consumers
is they never stay put it's always
moving
what about commute what about
communication portals
what do you think the opportunities are
in 2021 from
platforms how should they be thinking
about platforms um oh
you know whether it's digital whether
it's traditional
you know you've brought up burberry a
couple times so you know and and the
blazer
you know the fashion industry runway
show like what are you feeling in the
general marketing sphere
uh is opportunistic in 2021 yeah it's
really interesting because i was nodding
furiously when deborah mentioned
linkedin
being one and it's definitely my
favorite platform and i feel like it's
one where it's grown massively over the
last five years alone i feel like it's
underutilized because it's certainly a
great marketing tool if you think about
professionals
that have disposable income i'm amazed
that brands don't use it more
to try and like sell their products
right so available for paid partnerships
like seriously i'm there like the
biggest fan but
it's interesting you don't see it used
as much and i think that is something
that will change because they're talking
to people that have spare cash
like business people that have got jobs
and they're earning
you know back to the bigger point you're
making you feel like if burberry takes a
substantial social misstep
that you'll have the tear go down your
eye because you love the product so much
but
but where you are at 40 years young
because you look insane by the way
you look like my son and i'm 45. you
know
um do you feel like you have a little
bit of that tear in your eye but you're
at that place in your life's journey
where
that is the primary and you'll have to
go to a different brand
well no well actually a really good
example because we're talking about talk
negatively about brands but
actually a really good example where a
few years ago christopher bailey who was
the ceo openly gay
ceo the only one he dedicated his last
collection to the queer community
and he had the rainbow going through
lots of different i remember all of you
exactly and that brought it here to my
eye because
he overlooked the commercial
implications of supporting the queer
community given
where they sell their product middle
east russia
china he didn't care about the
implications it had for sales for him
it was about supporting the queer
community being visible
and then also donating a potential of
those profits to charities that actually
need it and support lgbt plus youth
for me that's that's activism
but when you're a company and the
fashion textile industry
as you know has data against what it
does to the environment
you know if the if your best friend is
skewing extremely passionate environment
you know i have friends who just don't
buy designer because
their biggest issue is textiles in you
know
gas and others obvious but this industry
is doing an enormous amount of
damage the real interesting question for
me over the next 20 years as consumers
become
so awake is will businesses
always have some vulnerability and then
people are choosing and picking like we
do in every issue
but for this textiles piece is around
sustainability and it's not just luxury
it's also
fast fashion in the uk
who was selling their clothes for like
99 pence
like if you think about taking that
through the supply chain how much those
people in asia being paid
to produce these products it's
outrageous yeah and obviously this is
the interesting thing where although
we'll have a big scandal about it people
will still buy it in their pounds like
buying all these products and it's just
confusing
what consumers will do and what they
won't i think that's an incredible way
to end it suki thank you so much for
your expertise
great to meet you such a pleasure next
we welcome
ec eggleston bracey the ceo
and evp of beauty and personal care at
unilever
he currently leads the 5 billion beauty
and personal care portfolio
and she founded dove's crown coalition
to eradicate
hair discrimination through support of
the crown act legislation
she's also held top roles at cody and
png
and has been recognized with numerous
awards welcome easy
hi thank you for having me good to talk
to you gary
always good to see you see uh let's get
right into it
um you know especially being at the helm
of such a big piece of business
which consumer behavior shifts will be
key to driving growth
in 2021. when you think about the
upcoming year
with all these incredible products under
uh
this category that you run where do you
see the biggest opportunity and then on
the flip side
what's giving you the most adjective
like you know we're a big company and i
don't think i'm gonna be able to move
fast enough in this thing and
i need to find some sort of hack or
solution yeah
i think what we will continue to see and
will become even more relevant
is the area of wellness and in self-care
you know your guest earlier today suka
and deborah they
we keep talking about the pandemic if
you talked about two pandemics i'd say
there's
four there's a health pandemic there's
the racial and equity pandemic
there's the economic crisis and then
there's the crisis of divisiveness in
total we saw living through the election
so because of all these things it's we
are under an incredible amount of stress
all of us i think something like 55 of
consumers say
i have more stress than i've ever had on
a daily basis
so what we have to do in terms of being
of service and helping people is helping
them take care of themselves
and when i think about self-care through
wellness it's two parts to it there's a
functional part
which is hygiene and the categories that
i lead in skin cleansing
and in hair and deodorant and skin care
there's the functional part we have a
range of new products
to address that and i can go through
what those are
the emotional part and the emotional
part
comes from identity being comfortable in
your own skin
you know things like dove's crown act
help with that
um making sure you're welcome and
included
but it's also that you have moments of
time out for yourself
and again in the markets that i lead you
know there's a lot you can do in the
shower
to get away from the kids who are
schooling at home it's true
the time in the shower and products that
make a difference there
help you change your hair style a little
bit of yeah just a little bit of perk up
in your skin
so wellness and self-care for sure
i like that talk to me about something
that's been a big theme today which is
speed
how do you feel about internally and
with the external partners that you're
working with in a 2021 world
what do you what do you feel like you
sit on speed and how do you feel about
speed
yeah from a speed perspective i actually
would first reflect to 2020.
okay always say crisis breeds invention
yes and i have seen you know my business
is about 5 billion in sales
you know hundreds of people on the
marketing team i have
seen the enterprise move like never
before
we literally launched into suave hand
sanitizers
in less than six weeks was not even
in our realm of what we were planning to
do
and i watched us
cut through all the process that we
would typically use
to make this happen so the question
really is so
for me i keep saying we've taught the
elephant how to dance and then we've
done it
over and over again in other areas we've
um
now have product i really love it's dove
nourishing hand sanitizer
it's like a this hand sanitizer is like
putting lotion on your hands it's
unbelievable
and that was something that was on our
plan but two years out and we ended up
doing that in less than a year and it's
really a technical innovation
so it's like we shown the elephant can
dance how do we keep the elephant
dancing
because we're all looking for that
relief we've cut corners we've moved
really fast
it's now how do we make that in our way
of working so
you asked how do i feel about speed in
2021
i feel like we've demonstrated we can
move fast now we're like cracking
our ongoing systemic ways of working so
that we can lean into those behaviors we
exhibit it
that bypass the system so it's now
actually the system
talk to me about cost of creative you
know where do you
what's the conversations the things
you're thinking about going into 2021
around
the notion of production cost that was a
big topic over the last six to nine
months i've heard from a lot of people
just the the the brief to the idea
all those meeting hours is that a
conversation that
you're going into with 2021 i think in
2021 we continue to want
cut through and i think what is in
today's world
you can't necessarily associate cut
through with cost and gary you know this
and what you do
there's so many ways to disrupt
without great cost and their ways that
you need to disrupt that take a lot of
cost depending on what the idea is so
we are putting a currency on the idea
and cut through
and in that cut through it's really
authenticity
and sometimes and again gary this is
what you do
and to get that cut through many times
authenticity
it's user generated content you know
it's someone with the camera
so it's less about policing production
cost
it's really driving impact overall
really using the full stream of tools
and assets that are available to us
in your category influencer marketing is
just a
wildly big and important conversation i
think it's a
early one so i'm fascinated to get your
perspective
on how you're thinking about that genre
in general
yeah influencer marketing i think
continues to evolve
and you know what you've heard a lot and
i know you also know is
authenticity is so important so there
was once
influencer marketing which was pay to
play
and as consumers and people were smart
we were people that are genuine
generally connected and committed and
when we find
general generally committed fans
who speak on behalf of a brand it
matters
so it continues to be an important part
but it's not a way for play
so micro influencers nano influencers
that are really credible
and then when you have macro influencers
they're ones that have some legitimacy
in the space and the product and the
category
and not just i have a big name let's use
that to drive influence
what what's the biggest observation what
was the biggest dotting the eye
or crossing the t for you intuition
going into 2020 that the
pandemic or some of the things you spoke
to in the first couple minutes here
really solidified like okay i had a
hunch
but this is really what i believe yeah
for me
2020 was all about and i'm going to say
human centricity so you know we
forever have been talking about in
marketing being consumer-centric
and you know unilever is a company that
believes it's what you do
it's not what you say so we believe in
purpose
2020 has so solidified that for me
because
when you think about people as consumers
you're ignoring everything else in their
life
what we consume how we interact with
products is one
little slice of our lives when we think
about
who we are as humans and then in that
context how we consume
products and how we can help with all
those issues
we grow we create impact and why 2020
really solidified that for me is we're
all dealing with
so much in our lives it's so far beyond
just how am i washing my hands
right what do i want on my hair it's how
it fits into the whole life
so arguably that's always been there but
we keep talking consumer centricity the
human centricity
and then it's what problems we can solve
that are outside of the product
in the product but what we do and again
i use dove crown act as an example of
that
on my dove men's business dove memphis
care
we're actually also partnering with the
national basketball players association
to help in harmful stereotypes that
actually kill black men
so we have a partnership with them where
we are highlighting
the athletes and who they are as humans
not just as athletes to change mindsets
and behaviors
and that's another example of human
centricity so we've
really made a commitment across brands
i've given too
i can give you a dozen of examples and
that will continue to be front and
center for us
on how we help with all the problems and
use our product
to help provide the wellness and the
self-care that i mentioned earlier
through
hand sanitization but also a moment of
time out i don't know if i mentioned
we're launching
a new brand we just launched with
walmart called find your happy place
we're all confined that's the thing with
the brand i think it's it's called find
your happy place
it's catching the sunrise it's under the
starlit sky
you know their moments because we want
to escape so that's another way we can
use our product
to help with what we want right we want
to get out of the house
house home for holidays but also take
the time to help with bigger issues
uh you see a little fun one on the way
out um what is the
favorite social network for you the
human
on your phone yeah i heard you earlier
guys talked about it
and for me it could it's ig it's
instagram
and it's because i'm incredibly visual i
can just get
quick information i get a sense for
what's going on without the depth and
then i can go into the depth so for me
my go-to
is still ig i love it and i really
appreciate your time
thank you for having me ciao hi
yes andrea next we welcome brad anderson
corporate vp of microsoft 365. brad has
built
four separate billion dollar businesses
at microsoft
including two from scratch riot hosts a
video series the ship room
which is an ita people
and a weekly live
all right brad i don't think you're
going to get the full uh the full intro
here i think andrea's having uh
wi-fi problems but we'll get into it
it's good to see you brother how are you
hey it's fantastic it's great to be here
you know i'm sitting here listening to
all these amazing people
talking thinking to myself wow you've
got these chief marketing officers and
i'm kind of the geeky engineering leader
here who happens to have a big social
presence and following that
that i get to do a lot of things with so
i'm really excited to be here thank you
before we get into it that picture
behind you is remarkable and kudos on
that talk about a win that's gorgeous
yeah actually you know it's funny five
children three grandchildren two more on
the way so uh
i stay busy at home and i stay busy at
work hey listen let's jump in
grant when did you start having children
12. look at you look amazing
you're kind no it's been fun it's been a
lot of fun and it's amazing
right hey let's what's your perspective
from your purview on consumer behavior
2021
um what are the opportunities what are
the shifts what are the key things that
companies need to be thinking about
yeah you know it's interesting i i sit
in this unique place where i get a
chance to see
how organizations and people work and
then you can take that insight you can
translate to how do the changes and how
people work how does that then translate
into
not only their consumer changes but how
all the organizations the service them
change
so you know microsoft we build what's
called office 365 most people probably
use it at work it's hundreds of millions
of users and
i build all the management security
around that so as you can imagine we do
a ton of research on how orgs and people
work
and i'll tell you in march and april of
this year we saw
multiple years of cultural change happen
and how orgs work
in two months and those changes will not
only have profound
impacts on the organizations but it's
going to have a profound impact on
all the organizations that service you
know the employees and and the orgs
themselves so let me just kind of lay it
out for you for a minute
you know like at march 12th at microsoft
we send everybody home
so you know on march 11th five percent
of the company was working remote on
march 12 98
was working from home and that was
common around the world you know we all
live on virtual meetings like we're
doing right now
um no travel um but but all those things
contributed to just people working a
different way now
and so you take those changes and say
all right what's going to happen
when the crisis is over and we come into
a new normal what is it going to look
like
first of all travel is going to drop
dramatically from a business perspective
and i was reading a
some research that bill gates had put
out and his view travel
is going to reduce by more than 50
percent and that makes sense to me i
think we've learned that we can have
meaningful conversations like this
over video and you know before when we
were going to close a big deal one of us
had to go out and travel and seal the
deal in person
you can now do that over video
second you know how many people are
going to want to work from home going
forward
you know the research that we show um 50
of people want to work from home two or
three days a week i hear cio's telling
me things like
on any given day as they plan for the
future fifty percent of the company will
be in the office it's going to be a
different fifty percent
every day how's that going to change
things i'll come back and give some
observations on that
and then finally if you think about it
if if half your people are working from
home or remotely
every meeting is going to be a virtual
meeting like we're on right now it's you
know kind of gone are the days when
everyone's going to be in the same room
so now translate that how does that then
impact changes in the market
you know first of all travel hospitality
all those businesses have got to think
differently about how
they thrive because business travel is
their most lucrative business
that's a fundamental change for them
huge you know think about
yeah think about all of the businesses
that what they do for a living is they
support other businesses whether that's
meals
maintenance you know cleaning whatever
the case may be is the amount of office
space that's going to be in use is going
to drop
you know i hear organizational leaders
telling me that they think they can free
up 30
of their office space
yeah and the amount is going to save him
is stunning you know one of the
questions i'll often ask is hey can you
give me an idea like roughly what does
it cost you to have an
office a dedicated office or a person
and kind of a number i hear a lot is
about 30
000 a year fully burdened you know if
you're a 10 000 person organization you
can save 3 000
um spots you're saving 90 million
dollars a year that you can now choose
to invest in other places
that's huge you know so that's gonna
have a change on how things
work and then finally um you know if you
think about what work
is now my experience like the experience
that you and i are having right now
this is the company to me the experience
yeah and so this is now the proxy for
the company
and organizations that are not putting a
world-class experience into the hands of
their people
are gonna have a hard time attracting
and retaining in fact you know some
research points out that um
of all the people under the age 35 45 of
them now
a core criteria in their decision making
is how good is the tech
that the company's going to enable me
with of course i mean
i think that number i mean basically the
thing i most hear
anecdotally from people under 30 is
making fun of
the software that their company uses
it's like a huge common theme like
they're you know as you know and you're
in this space
a lot of the tech you know is built and
it's
world renowned and then just like
anything in life
7 12 13 years later it's a frankenstein
of what it was
it's slower than the alternatives and
it's becau you know
i mean microsoft at google facebook
every company
that's ever won started by disrupting
in its lack of friction and then get
then the real challenge is disrupting
yourself
before somebody else disrupts you that's
right you know in the case of microsoft
you know if you go back a decade
you know we had built world-class
capabilities about delivering on-premise
products but that's all moved to the
cloud now
and you know we're one of the companies
that has figured out how to make that
transition but it's not you know a
business model change is a very hard
transition to make it through
but here's some stunning data just to
give you an idea of of the research that
we're now doing on this on this employee
experience piece
and just to build on your point a little
bit you know what we
hear is is
is these individuals come back when we
interview employees and they go like
the technology that i have in my
personal life is
so much better than the technology that
i have in my business life
is unacceptable you need to have that's
not even close by the way
i mean i'm having that's right and so
it's happening it's happening with
with with live stream software right
it's
you know we're having meetings where i'm
literally having meetings with
individuals in fortune 500 companies
where they're using their personal
emails because they want to use a
different software
because the one that their organization
is stuck in
because it's more secure it doesn't have
a feature or isn't
innovating as quickly it just it makes
sense it's david and goliath it's just
it's a very real thing yeah and it's so
interesting there's been kind of this
tyranny of or that you can give a great
user experience or it can be secure
and for for the last couple of decades
it kind of feels like we've been caught
in that
that's not the case any longer as we
bring all these cloud services together
and so it's interesting is we've as we
work with some of these organizations
that have transformed and they're
putting this amazing experience in the
hands of their users
where users look at and go like this is
every bit as good as what i have in my
personal life
here's just three data points that i
think are fascinating and this is for
every leader in a company
to ask themselves would you want these
three data points first of all
when you put world-class technology to
work that your employees can use
your employees are 121 percent more
likely to feel valued
by your company that's loyalty
that's longevity they're going to work
harder
they're 59 percent more likely to say
that tech not that technology enables
them to better serve their customers
customer mps and satisfaction is going
to go up and finally
this is an amazing number these
organizations are seeing a full
75 point increase in the internal net
motor score and ps from their employees
as they
give them a wonderful experience you
know you know gary
if as a product owner if i see a way to
get a five or ten point increase in mps
boy you go all in because that's a big
move
these organizations are literally seeing
a 75 point which i think is two things
one
they're coming from a really poor
experience and then two they're landing
on a great experience
but those i think are the trends you
have to deliver this world-class
experience to your users because they're
going to be working from everywhere
and as people work from everywhere it's
going to change how orgs work and it's
going to change how all the
organizations that support them
serve their customers thinking about all
the efficiency talk well i got one more
minute
something spurred as i was listening to
you just curious from your perspective
brad
where common sense sits in the current
equation
of business and marketing just one man's
point of view you know just kind of
listening to you hack here a little bit
i like it just
very intuitively curious where do you
think the responsibility for more common
sense less comments like
where's common sense in today's business
environment from your perspective
yeah when you say common sense you know
one of the words that comes to my mind
is simplicity
you know so much of as you talk about
you know
your question things get very
complicated very quick and you know
people glaze over
and so i think about simplicity as an
engineering leader as an architectural
principle but i also think about that as
an architectural principle of how we
communicate
i think we just have to be really clear
and really simple in
all the communications and not try to
hide behind a bunch of acronyms and
technology
talk people want to people want to have
a clear
and an honest view of what they can do
with your technology
brad i really appreciate your time happy
happy holidays hey same to you thank you
next we welcome heather malencheck svp
and cmo of landa lakes
all right i like where andrea's frozen
there heather
why don't you give everybody a little uh
sense of uh give twist 20 seconds of
what you do now in your career
yeah so i'm i'm the newly appointed uh
cmo for uh the wonderful land of lakes
company based in minnesota
and um super super excited to be here
i've been here at the company about
three months now so
i'm really excited to come here sorry
just getting into it yeah and your prior
gig
because i think a lot of people will
know that brand as well
yeah so uh chief marketing officer of a
little known brand harley davidson
so uh yeah well uh had the
real fortune in my career of working
with some amazing brands
heather you you continue uh this
incredible lineup of really
you know incredible marketers so i'm
really excited to ask you this which
from your perspective which consumer
behavior shifts
will be key uh for brands to figure out
and take advantage of to drive business
growth
yeah so you know really interesting
listening to folks uh
talking earlier today i think that you
know the big one i would say is there's
so many social norms shifting and i
think
i think it was uh might be an essay that
was saying i mean we don't really know
what's going to be happening
in six months time we can all you know
there's a lot of conjecture
what we've seen and what we're i think
is going to be one of the permanent
changes is the way people shop
so um that's certainly you know our
shift to digital was fast
and furious um i think the other one is
sort of the
the view of home so as maybe less of a
social place more of a private place so
the way that people think about their
homes is a little different
we've actually benefited from some of
that you know people are at home
cooking baking and so you know that's
part of what our efforts are
uh have been really good we've sold more
butter this year i think than we've ever
sold
um the other piece that's really
interesting and it kind of connects back
to
uh what we were talking about previously
um with uh with brad is this
this idea of digital in the shift to
digital so you know we
um we are a farmer-owned co-op so some
of us
most people would know us as a butter
company but we're actually a
farmer-owned co-op so we're owned by
um farmers across america and um a big
part of our role is supporting those
farmers so
as you think about we really have this
farmer to fork structure so all the way
from
rural community and the farmer and the
seeds and the soil health all the way
through to
you know butter and the products on your
table and and what's been really
interesting about this digital
piece is um and it relates back to some
of the work that we're doing at london
lakes is there's a huge digital divide
in this country that we sometimes forget
about so
we can sit here today and we take
somewhat for granted the fact that we
have high-speed internet so we're
able to work from home or we're having
this great conversation or on zoom all
the time
when in fact there are about 18 million
americans
who don't have access to high-speed
internet so just think about that for a
second you've got
kids who are in rural communities who
are not not able to do distance learning
you know people can't get access to
medical help
or farmers who don't have the data that
they need to be able to run profitably
so
we're actually part of a
we're leading a coalition of companies
actually microsoft included
around this thing called american
connection project which is really
trying to bridge that digital divide
and push for funding and policy around
getting
getting broadband into some of these
communities rural and underserved
so it's a it's a it's one of those
things i think
you know as we think about what's
happening this year and what's going to
be
really important going into next year
that uh i'm going to bring to the table
heather you're you're only 100 days in
it sounds like you know
actually i'm going to go in a different
angle because i'm trying to bring as
much value in this program as possible
what what should
individuals here that are taking
leadership roles and new organizations
think about in their first hundred days
right you've you've ascended in your
career so i'm sure this has happened
more than once you're
in the prime of your career from my
opinion at this point so
what have you learned do you have any
tried and true principles
of things that people should consider
when they first enter a new leadership
role in an organization that they
haven't been in
before no matter how much homework they
did or prep to be part of that
con company excuse me yeah i mean this
is this is definitely a challenging time
to come in and be a new leader in a
company
um but i would say i mean my you know my
first and foremost is always connecting
with the team
and so that's been no different in how
i've come into line of the lake so
really spending time with the team
figuring out the talent on your team
and i don't mean direct reports i mean
all levels of the organization so i've
spent my first 100 days really
getting to know the team how we work and
my peers in the organization uh and
spending time with them as well so i
think connecting on a human level
i think with everybody has been really
important um
and this you know the zoom environment
has been great and i
i've been the benefactor i think of the
team has been working really well
virtually so i've waltzed in in
september and they're so good at it that
that's helped me get ahead of the game
um but it's really about
connecting on human level and i think
particularly now
everybody is feeling this uh this
pandemic in lots of different ways
you've got
you know we talk a lot about parents who
have distance learning and have to be
teachers so you've got to take that into
account but you've also got
people on your team who are single and
living alone
and feeling levels of incredible
isolation
so um i think it's just it's just really
important to connect on a human level
really understand
the dynamic there
themes of this talk speed contextual
creative
cost of creative your overall kind of
state of the union of 2020
things that around those themes that
stood out or
anticipations or affirmations or
considerations for 2021
yeah i mean that you know agile's such
an overused term and i know you talk
about this a lot right it drives me a
little crazy we need to be more agile
um and i think we do um but i i look at
our operating model and i'm looking at
that with the team now and i think we'd
really
some cases you have to slow down to
speed up so really we're really looking
at our
processes and driving at some of the
inefficiencies it's kind of what deborah
was talking about earlier too
to enable us to be uh to accelerate our
progress i would say and be in that
space so i think that's a big part of it
um costa creator you know i have i am
blessed with a company that has
so many stories uh to talk about that
um you know storytelling is a big part
of it and i think
the authenticity comes through when you
don't have these big
cinematic productions but actually in
just telling those human stories so
we are probably more down that path and
i see us
you know continuing to do that as well i
think i think the other piece gary is
just
you know we talk a lot about brand
relevance and i think cultural relevance
today is critical
so you know cultural competency of an
organization and that goes
way beyond marketing but really staying
too and i
loved what essie was talking about in
terms of human centricity because it is
about that it's about really
understanding what else is going on in
people's lives and how you fit in there
but it relates to how we hire people and
how hr think about it your brand
supply chain you know everything
everybody in the company really needs to
be
culturally competent these days and um
and that's a that's a
full full-time ongoing effort that's not
something you do a study for once a year
that's something that you really need to
be
it's more of a breaking it's more of a
breaking news capability than making a
documentary right
yeah exactly exactly and i think i think
that's a big place and i think about you
know
sometimes we miss the cultural insights
you know market research companies
traditional market research companies i
think missed the boat on that um
often times they'll be doing studies in
a more traditional way that completely
miss the social impact that the work
might have
you know so i think we need to really
think differently about how we develop
those insights as well
i think sometimes the best way to think
about what's going to happen over the
next five years
is by understanding missteps or
or things that really worked well in the
last five years when you think back of
the real revolution of this device and
marketing as you know it
you've probably evolved a lot as a
marketer what stands out as the thing
that
you really feel like oh you know six
years ago
i had this point of view and wow has the
last five years really taught me that i
wasn't on the right side of history
there you know whether you know because
it's empowering you know i love when i'm
wrong
i love having conviction i'm passionate
but i mean it i love it because it's
like
the game is humbling you and you're like
okay you know no matter how much you
know and so
anything stand out when i say that maybe
last two three four years maybe
something that helped in our harley or
you as a consumer anything stand out
because i think sometimes that pattern
recognition helps for the future
yeah i think um i'm trying i think the
shift to mobile because
mobile because i think in some ways
digital always made
total sense to me what i always worry
about to be honest gary is i worry that
we
over correct and swing the pendulum you
go too far
like we start doing ar executions before
the consumer's there
yeah right it's the biggest reason
either that i get upset when people are
like
oh you're a disrupter you're a few i'm
like no no no i am practical
what you believe in is yesterday i have
no interest
in tomorrow other than keeping an eye
about it but what i'm
thinking and passionate about is
storytelling
building brand creating results today
yeah exactly yeah so i really worry
about this over correction so
even though i know as we talk about the
digital shift that's happened the
significant shift that's happened this
year
um there will be a point where i i don't
think that
means that we never ever ever again go
down some of the more traditional routes
because that'll that'll happen too so i
just i always
i'm always worried about over correcting
and swinging the pendulum way too far
so i think that's right i think i think
that's a huge mistake by some people
that are
super progressive and then the other the
middle
is a beautiful place thank you so much
thank you so much
next we welcome john levy he's a
behavioral scientist
and founder of the influencers a secret
dining experience and private community
which we hope he'll share more about
john is launching his second book in may
called you're invited
the art and science of cultivating
influence
thank you welcome john thanks for having
me this is so fun
hey john so uh what should we talk about
today
should we dive into some neuroscience or
some uh fun marketing stuff
you know i think that's one of the same
sometimes if you decide to frame it up i
think
you know i think it'd be great from a
behavioral scientist kind of point of
view
what is your biggest prediction of
things we should be thinking about or
looking out for in 2021 and how they may
impact uh the opportunities for
the individuals that want to storytell
so i think one of the most
interesting things is that we are
there's a complete lack of novelty right
so most people are just reproducing
other people's content
slightly differently but there's a
section of the brain called the
snvta what it stands for doesn't really
matter
but it's the major novelty center of the
brain and it responds relative to how
new or different something is
and when it responds it actually causes
you to want to explore and understand it
it makes you want to go out there and
see it or experience the brand or
participate
right now i'm seeing a lot of brands
that are really playing it safe
a lot of that probably has to do with
cancel culture people are scared of
saying the wrong thing and then being
completely canceled out
but the fact is that we won't stand out
and we won't be remarkable
in any meaningful way if we're not
willing to do something novel
and the interesting thing is that when
we do something novel
the brain responds by uh with
neuroplasticity
we're literally creating new memories
and not just the experience or that idea
that's novel is more memorable
but everything the brand the smells the
tastes
and so i think one of the things that
we're really going to need to look at is
how do we create novelty within the
limitations and
how we're confined by being in our homes
and so how will brands actually
accomplish that
uh the second thing that i'm really
seeing is that
uh in 1984 the average american had
three close friends besides family by
2004
that was two nowadays
it's probably even less and we're
dealing with a loneliness epidemic
which means that if we don't do
something about it it'll actually impact
people's health
being lonely is on par with smoking a
pack a day of cigarettes
in terms of impact but this also means
what's your what's your perspective two
things on that
a what's how do
how do those reports get created you
know i'm always curious by that okay
cool which report in 84 how many people
so a those reports in 84 and 2004 how
are they created just to educate the
audience
and then b what's your hypothesis on
that momentum
uh so the uh those reports if memory
serves come from a really large study
of thousands of people across america
that's done every year by university of
chicago
okay and so they ask questions that are
supposed to be relevant and every single
and they just add that question
uh and then why do i think that trend is
i think it's a few things the first is
uh as it got less expensive to travel
and people
moved more then we would be more distant
from our
friends and more isolated as a byproduct
and then my hunch is that trend
increased even more because when you
look at loneliness statistics
uh jen's ears are the most lonely uh
and they feel like they are understood
the least and least connected
which i think brings me the this
incredible opportunity for brands
which is that i think the brands that
are really going to succeed
are the ones that can provide a sense of
belonging
ultimately we want to feel like we're
part of something
and we're not getting that from our
social communities
because we're so isolated and so if you
can do that like
uh heather just came on she was talking
about harley-davidson where she used to
work
that organization has an incredible
level of belonging for its members
and customers and so there's a oh
sorry no no please go ahead there's a
bunch of really interesting ways that uh
companies can do that
and they're completely non-intuitive uh
the first is most brands think that if
i'm really
or most people think if i'm really nice
to you gary you're going to
like me more and that's probably true to
some degree
but human beings have this thing called
the ikea effect
and it says that we disproportionately
care about our ikea furniture because we
had to assemble it
and so what we actually want to do is
find ways to get our customers
to invest effort into us as brands john
quick because i always think a lot about
parenting nature nurture
on the lonely aspect any thoughts on
modern parenting
like i think a lot about entitlement oh
yeah
you know i think i think there's a macro
trend that people continue to not talk
about which is
every empire creates incredible
vulnerability
just around the place where america is
in its dominance
and i think a lot of that has to do with
the fruitfulness
and the wealth and the power and
obviously there's incredible pockets of
poverty and other issues in this country
but
in the macro america's standing in the
world for 100 years
thoughts about loneliness from a
parenting dynamic anything from your
observation studies
science behavior life so i i absolutely
love that you brought this up
there was a great book called coddling
of the american mind by john hate
uh nyu professor brilliant and one of
his biggest arguments
is that human beings are anti-fragile
which means that there are things that
are fragile you drop a glass it'll break
there are things that are robust you hit
a building nothing will happen to it but
then human beings are anti-fragile
which means it's like lifting weights
you repair muscle and it grows back
stronger
and when we get too comfortable
we atrophy we become weaker and
this generation and generation after
generation
we've actually coddled them to the point
that they're in college
and now they don't need to speak to
their own teachers to say i need an
extension
mom or dad will email the professor
saying my child is
special and needs more time for a test
but as a byproduct if we don't learn
those social skills and how to navigate
them then we're going to end up
weaker as a byproduct and we're seeing
it as gen z is entering the workforce
this issue that hr doesn't really know
how to
how to connect with them in the same way
so to speak to your point about
loneliness
uh when you have an a generation that
has been
generally coddled that told that you
know their opinion matters more than
other people's
and that if they don't like something
they don't have to hear it
then they never had to build any
strength in order to
to deal with other people's opinions or
corporate issues or any of these other
things
and uh and so
they're probably less prepared to deal
with isolation
then you also then have when that
becomes the realization that the
individuals that parented in that
ecosystem have less interest in being
accountable
for that creation so it's easier to
blame so i i first of all i have a ton
of respect for
the difficulty of parenting parenting
it's
the hardest yeah but it doesn't
everything's hard doesn't mean that we
shouldn't have more thoughtful
conversations because i think we've gone
very pointing instead of thumbing so i
i think that there's a ton that needs to
be explored here
right and when you speak to parents
you're you often hear things like
well all the other parents uh let their
kids have cell phones so what do you
want me to do
and i respect that that's an issue i
think the question is where
uh what do we want to prepare people for
and what is it that you actually have
bandwidth because if you have two jobs
and you're barely making ends meet then
there's
only so much bandwidth for other things
uh and i think that there's just a ton
of complexity there
i love it john thank you so much for
being on the show brother we appreciate
this angle which i think brings
value to the combo
last but not least we welcome daryl m
blocker
retired cia operative and ceo of mosaic
daryl has had a 32-year career in the
u.s intelligence community
and was the most senior black cia
officer and the directorate of
operations
with a rank equine to a three-star
general before joining the corporate
world
daryl is an abc news contributor and
serves two great non-profits
daryl now lives in la after a lifetime
residing and working in foreign
countries
in africa asia and europe welcome daryl
i really appreciate being here and nice
to nice to meet you and see you as well
gary
it's a real pleasure daryl so you know
obviously you have an incredibly uh
i like how it has retired on the ca cia
operative i
you you actually do retire you it's not
the mafia
from your perspective and and coming
from your angle which is why we run it
out real
a bunch of different angles here what do
you see from consumer behavior
that is uh an enabler to growth in 2021
or observations or opportunities
well the guest that you had on about two
iterations ago
talked about how corporate america
ten months ago would never have
considered the fact that
they could run a business with most of
their personnel
not physically in a you know a
brick-and-mortar location
and at this point it's not going to go
back
to what it was all these businesses are
going to have to recognize that
that the paradigm has shifted and so
from someone who's looking at it from
the perspective of someone involved in a
you know intelligence and security firm
two things jump out at me the
global internet of things which includes
you know
pandemic fatigue which could include
insider threat or insider risk or
insider trusts however
your company defines it and it is going
to change
when you go from being on a system at
work to your using your own private
you know your private devices your
laptop your your ipad and your phone
which of course are all connected
and if the you know the the bad guy so
to speak someone trying to steal your ip
is has access to one then essentially
they have access to all
so looking at the internet of things
looking at uh the vulnerability of
people's home
systems and not being um not being as
diligent as if they would
in the in the office space is is a
vulnerability that i think
everyone should be concerned with and as
an ancillary to that
the mental health of your workers most
people
enjoyed getting up and leaving the home
there were stresses at home that you
could kind of get away from
in the workplace and now that they're
both combined that stress is there
the stress of course causes people to do
things that they might not otherwise do
including uh opening up a an email
a phishing email that you know allows
the somebody to have
system access that you would otherwise
not want them to do
so just the fatigue of dealing with the
pandemic
and the stress of you know maybe not
being able to meet your mortgage
might make you more liable to
fall for you know the uh you know the
outreach from
a firm that's really you know the
chinese government or the russian
government or whoever it is that's
targeting you
what do you what do you think is most
fascinating about
the marketing that you consume have you
gotten a sense of your own self at this
point in your life of the things that
capture your attention and you get
excited about i
i do and so essentially i have three
kind of
bailiwicks that i'm i'm involved in now
um so i'm doing my creative side i'm
working with entertainment
media ventures and we're creating human
interest stories with a twist of
espionage so i'm able to
kind of pull in some of my past lives
into
uh into my creative world and
there is an art to an intelligence and
there's some science to it as well
um but i'm tapping into the creative
side
i'm working with with foster youth and
kind of tying in some of those stories
into my creative side and for mosaic
of um of which i'm still kind of
involved in the intel security work
i'm doing some of the things like
tracking down
uh defrauders and so all my worlds
all the things that i truly enjoy doing
reading studying
figuring out puzzles i'm able to kind of
do with foster youth and you know youth
that
have a foster care experience for peace
for kids i'm able to tie that into
a storyline for a you know for a pitch
that might be coming up
on the hollywood side of what i'm doing
and
i'm also pursuing that through mosaic
and chasing you know chasing bad guys
i'm not chasing al qaeda or
isis anymore but there are a lot of bad
people out there doing a lot of bad
things to people that
love them people that were partnered
with them some people that were even
you know related to them so i have three
passions and i get to use them all
kind of simultaneously how you know just
to take a left field
uh turn for some of the entrepreneurs
that are listening you know
what are your recommendations around
self-awareness and patience and
you know context and pattern recognition
some of the things that i'm sure
inevitably
led to you being in a place where you're
still a young man and able to do all
your passions any thoughts on like
tried and true principles that give you
the leverage to be in a happy state in
what you do
trust it really boils down to trust
trust is the currency of an intelligence
operative
trust is the currency of every marketing
uh
strategy that's ever been developed and
so i work a lot on building trust and
you build trust slowly
you build trust by by making sure that
person that you're dealing with the
person that you're talking with feels
valued
that they feel that they actually have a
role in whatever mission you have
laid out the new campaign for lando
lakes or
for harley or for the cia they're really
not that different and it boils down to
the personal
connections that you should have
with your employees if you only know
them as you know whatever their
employee number is or the job that they
do then you're not doing
enough because their cubby will probably
give you a little
about who they are whether they're a
sports fan or whether
you know they prefer animals or they got
pictures of their grandchildren
or whatever it is people decorate
themselves
in a way that allows you to engage them
on a personal level without
making it kind of creepy but once people
feel like you actually see them
that you actually care about how they
spent their weekend or
not just the latest numbers that need to
be be provided so
building trust and it's a daily thing
it's a daily outreach
and it should never be a drain it should
just be as easy as breathing
as easy as walking into the office and
acknowledging that person
when someone walks into your office
control alt delete
that person could have gone anywhere in
the world but they came to you
that level of uh intimacy when it comes
to connecting
with your people build on that talk to
me about the role
from your perspective given your career
and your angles and your observations
around intuition
you know intuition is intuition is
ingrained into our dna we are the only
species
on the planet that talks ourselves out
of something that we know could be
dangerous
and that then you know whether the hair
is falling up on the back of your neck
intuition is huge um the
the cia when they're looking for someone
like myself someone who is an
operations officer and not a spy i'm a
spy handler
recruited and handled spies and there's
semantics but there is a huge difference
and what they're looking for is a
collection of intellectual social
and personality traits that allow you to
be affable that allow you to be
resilient that allow you
to engage uh in other cultures
and and and learn more about the person
that you're talking
to than yourself and wanting them to
list so listening is huge
and one of the wisest people i ever knew
who just happens to be my ex-wife
says that listening is not waiting for
your turn to speak
so if you think you're a good listener
um
i would surmise that you should ask your
partner and um
and then work on it from there because i
can pretty much guarantee you that
you're not the listener that you think
you are
do you think that people have different
listening styles because uh
this is a category that i spend a lot of
time i'm surprised
by how into me or or
i actually use talking to listen i i
haven't gone deep
in this to educate myself on what they
are but i'm extremely aware of its truth
and i
see it in others as a listening
mechanism
have you explored listening enough to
add to this
conversation in context i i cause i
think people silence
is not listening i see it every day
right
yes i agree i agree because
listening is is more than just with your
ears you're listening with
you know with your with your with your
being literally and people
every one of us has been in a
conversation where the person you're
talking to
is doing this motion and you know
they're just waiting
for their turn to speak so they're not
really engaged they're not really
listening to you
um when you're not being listened to
look for the body signs you'll you'll
know if you're not getting through the
person starting to fidget
you're looking for anything that
suggests that their brain is
or their thoughts are are elsewhere so
you learn how to listen to the agent
who's telling you
these secrets who's telling you things
about them that they've never shared
with anyone else you're listening when
the ambassador calls you in
and talks about how something you're
doing might
impact uh american policy you learn how
to
listen a lot more or you end up on the
uh
on the wrong side of history in our
organization getting on
getting on the um you know being in
front of however many people we're in
front of right now is just not a place
most people at cia want to be so
listening keeps you out of trouble as
well
i really appreciate your insights my
friend i wish you a tremendous
holiday and i think you brought a lot
more context to this incredible event
thank you
i really appreciate the time thank you
andrea
last one of the season i thought it was
an
unbelievable one thoughts from your
perspective if you can even talk because
your wi-fi has been
very thank you no i love that we ended
on listening because
we can't thank all of our all those that
have been here
with us on this journey we'd love to
listen and hear more about what you'd
like in
2021 what you liked about 2020 so hit us
up on marketingforthenow
at gmail.com uh but yeah just if this
this journey has been a tremendous one
and gary love you um
you know great great way of pushing us
in different directions and allowing
people to contribute
with all their comments along the way
thank you for that thank you for you the
team
um maybe georgie and summer want to come
on screen so we can give them a little
love they've been
incredibly uh instrumental in
the production and and organization of
this so i don't know if they're going to
go humble and not show up on the screen
but i'd love for them to come and just
wave real quick but other than that
i just want to thank everybody who's
been watching uh
this year uh obviously it's something we
are looking to continue next year
we were you know obviously i'm reading a
lot of the comments from the live
streams
in real time big shout out to stream
yard for the infrastructure that allows
me to do that which
um has enabled us to really create some
high-level events and
we you know andrea will tell you if i
wasn't on the screen right now i'm
pushing her to continue to elevate
uh the people that we put on the screen
and
and mix up the perspectives and bring
different values and i hope everybody
got a ton of value i hope everybody has
a tremendous
tremendous uh 2021 and a holiday and new
year's and all that and thank you for
your time
we've got an episode coming up in
january on january 21st
so we'll see you hopefully at noon on
thursday january 21st
happy holidays